well this is it after six years nanny
the month is packing it in the nut
before one last hurrah growing
vegetables selling Chipotle burritos
photoshopping models sleeping in cars
feeding the homeless wearing naughty
Bay's yoga pants over the years busy
bodies have been itching to bust you for
all of those crimes they've targeted
happy meals bikini baristas condomless
porn tiny gun shaped lighters raw milk
rare burgers live music fish pedicures
and a bazillion other things but for the
very last nanny we head to the Hamptons
for a story that highlights why we may
be completely and utterly doomed so
here's the deal East Hampton Village
shut down a lemonade stand and yes
you're we've heard stories like this so
many times you almost forget to be
outraged but here's why we might be
completely and utterly doomed one
someone saw a lemonade stand and called
the cops you know the people of
handcuffs and guns it's the Hamptons so
the killjoy probably dialed 911 to a cop
actually responded 3a cops shut down the
lemonade stand even though is run by
Jerry Seinfeld and his son in other
words celebrity the one force that could
plausibly overpower our control freak
culture got squeezed like an overripe
Eureka in a gorilla cage thanks for
following nanny the month on Twitter
thanks for submitting your nanny
nominees and thanks for griping along
for six years nanny out